[Music]
gretel-ann Hansel so Gretel and Hansel
is a telling of the story of Hansel and
Gretel you know the story a couple kids
find this cabin in the woods and there's
a little lady who lives there and turns
out she cooks kids and eat something
that's the grim fairy tale anyway this
does have a bit of a different twist on
it not just the title but judging by the
title Gretel is the star of the movie
the difference and I think this is a
spoiler and I don't really I don't have
the motivation to watch the trailer I
remember seeing this in the trailer so
leave you light spoilers that it's not
really spoiling anything the main
difference in this one is the witch is
like oh I see something in this girl
maybe she can be my apprentice anyhow
that's the main difference they're
trying to figure it out there's old ones
like here's some plant to fulfil yang
children who are really hungry anyhow
right so there are things that I liked
in the movie first of all the rock star
of the movie Alice Krige because ever
since I saw Alice Krige and Star Trek
first contact as the Borg Queen I was
like yeah she's a rock star in my book
maybe because I'm a Trekkie sure but I
thought she was really good in here she
has some great lines well there be
self-serving manipulation or just a line
where you're like oh like that there's
some philosophy there we're gonna say oh
no I thought she completely stole the
show those are my favorite moments is
when they're in the house and Gretel's I
Han saw I felt like was kind of a prop
so it's really Gretel story and there's
a silent tension that's going on there
and I liked it and let me have some
entertaining yet interesting tone what I
mean by tone is that it's not always the
same tone I mean you can argue the
movies supposed to feel like it has two
different tones because one is the lie
you know the world with the veil pulled
over at the lie that the witch is
creating that they're kind of dealing
with and when they start seeing past it
then you have the real world which is
much darker but no that exists and then
there's the other tone which you feel
like you just kind of slipped into the
movie Mandy it goes from the witch to
Mandy but not in a way that always feels
like it mixes and works but rather in a
way where someone saw the witch and
Mandy and said well if I make them go
splat
maybe I mean a couple kids hanging out
in the cabin eating at the table with a
witch and she has a lot of food it feels
exactly how you think ooh creepy woods
and there's a silhouette it's talking
like a cozy to the darkness the veil is
lifting and then at one point in the
movie there's this red light coming from
behind a tree a silhouette you got the
synthesized music laggy
[Music]
that is from a completely different
movie really that tone only happens a
couple times maybe that's why it feels
out of place I mean it's interesting I
thought it was cool it just didn't feel
like it's from this movie maybe they
were saving on budget maybe they were
like we want Hellfire and edema now we
don't have the budget for that okay well
we'll put a red light behind a tree you
got the synthesized music ready great
work for that movie with Nick Cage let's
just do it admittedly maybe the reason
I'm crying about it right now is because
I actually did like that tone when it
came on I wish they committed to using
it more I remember a couple times
speaking of budget did the budget that
didn't work there was one scene where if
they spent more money on the visual
effects scene would have been sweet but
instead I saw the scene and I was like
again what you were trying to do really
sweet concept and a couple times in this
movie you feel like that conversation
went down where they're like alright
well it's it deals with witches in the
woods so we're just gonna have creepy
imagery because creepy imagery but you
don't really know why it happens at a
point you're convinced there are about
10 witches in these woods there aren't
it's just the one actually kind of feels
like it was directed by three people cuz
when this movie started out it felt like
a student film from 2005 films in 2005
on a canon XL - and I hope we get a good
grade for this and they get to the cabin
and it's like oh the budgets up now
there's a scene where she's walking in
the woods you're like Ken and xl2 from
2005 so between that the cabin and the
Mandy young be three different people
also it wasn't a fan of the voiceover in
this movie this movie has voiceover
sometimes you hear what she's thinking
about any given situation I really feel
like the voiceover in this movie was
just an afterthought anything that was
said with the voiceover I feel like
could have just been illustrated through
actions or I'm imagining the movie
without any voice over with nothing
change and that completely works as well
I personally just didn't see the need
for a voiceover it's felt out of place
in the end I'm kind of 50/50 on this
movie there are some things I like most
of it was in the cabin some visuals I
like some of it didn't really mix I like
they're from two different movies weird
way I feel like they left is over for
some cinematic universe or something a
grimm fairy tales cinematic universe I
can totally see that happening after
this and I'm gonna dip it's not the best
movie I saw this January it's not the
worst
it's Gretel and Hansel it simply
happened I'll say it probably be a
better time if you're drunk yeah no it's
a bounty I'm bigger
and I want to thank the sponsor of this
video this video is brought to you by
audible audible is an audiobook service
that I use via the app on my phone pale
blue dot by Carl Sagan makes those
drives to the screening a little less
painful so I guess that's my official
audio book recommendation pale blue dot
by Carl Sagan it's always a good time
for astronomy and science besides Carl
Sagan reading his own audio book sound
of the Gods so click the link below to
go to audible.com slash John's or text
John's to five hundred five hundred and
get yourself one free audiobook and two
audible originals for you to listen to
for that's right free along with your
30-day free trial you want more huh I
like your style
turns out audible is issuing a challenge
for new and current members finish three
audiobooks by a March 3rd and get
yourself twenty dollars in Amazon credit
just remember finished three by three
three so again click the link below to
audible.com slash John's or text John's
to five hundred five hundred and get
your audiobook on and once again thank
you to audible for sponsoring this video
I appreciate it we're so Gretel and
Hansel have you seen it what did you
think about it what's a fairy tale that
you'd like to see like a nice dark take
on I mean they're all kind of talking
messed up okay go wild whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]